[Music]  back at the Awards these fiancees made  their red carpet debut  Pete Davidson wearing an Ag D bracelet  before ariana grande takes his last name  both gave us PBA all night long  including this thanks for existing that  got some odds from the crowd it was  family night for Ariana with her aunt  grandma Marjorie and mom Joan joining  her on stage after Marjorie aka Nona had  some fun backstage I'm the audience her  fiance and brother bonded after Frankie  talked to Kelty does Frankie grande  approve of Pete is the question listen  my sister's super happy so I proved you  know I'm definitely in the bridal party  and we're sorting out everything as of  now but I mean I'm definitely gonna be  the gay of honor another wedding party  member mother of the groom Amy Davidson  was seen backstage cheering on her  future daughter-in-law right after  performing at 10:37 Ariana and Pete  bailed for another grande set at the  after-party 92 year old Nona in tow  [Music]